michael wendler gilt ja als einer der
bekanntesten deutschen stars und nun hat
er sich selbst ins abseits geschossen
sie haben sich da auch zu dem thema
mehrfach geäußert auch so unter
finanziellen aspekten war das jetzt
wirklich ein riesenfehler oder wie
beurteilen sie die situation heute ja
gut das ist das ganze jetzt gute drei
wochen her und mittlerweile ist so ein
bisschen der schaden ersichtlich alle
parteien und es geht ja nicht nur um
michael wendler und seine frau laura die
natürlich extremsten schaden erlitten
haben aus eigener schuld muss man ja
dazu sagen sondern da hängt ja noch
viele partner firmen usw dran
da habe ich jetzt mal ist ganz stimmt
kann es schon mal so ein bisschen
gelichtet und hab mal durchatmen können
sie kunst vorstellen dass natürlich auch
viele anfragen von presse und so die
ganze zeit war da kam ich irgendwie habe
ich mir zu trinken wie luft soll und
dass man zu durchdenken jetzt ist gerade
ein bisschen ruhiger mann hat ja gestern
gesehen michael wendler hat ein
statement dazu abgegeben damit bin ich
noch nicht ganz einverstanden und
zufrieden
für mich ist das ganze thema erst vorbei
für ihn wenn er aus halle telekom-profi
bilder statt weil sich da natürlich
viele leute auch tummeln die krude
theorien verbreiten und dementsprechend
erwarte ich da noch auf ein großes
zeichen von ihm und dann glaube ich gibt
es auch wieder eine chance für ihn
irgendwann wieder auf die deutschen
bühnen zurückzukehren oder vielleicht
auch wieder entfernt ich bin kein
hellseher aber ich habe in dieser
branche schon ganz andere kai aus der
kiste wieder kommen sehen
die menschen vergessen sehr schnell das
ist manchmal gut manchmal nicht so gut
in unserem fall ist jetzt glaube ich gar
nicht so schlecht aber es hat musiker
und sänger und funktioniert meistens
über ein hit oder über einen song wenn
da was gutes kommt glaube ich hat er
auch eine chance immer wieder
zurückzukehren